So I don't know about you, but I have been
to three different arenas today.
I thought I would check them all out before
coming here!
Thank you for your patience, and thank you,
Ellie, for entertaining you while I was setting
up.
So we are talking about ES2019 features today.
How many are using ES2019 features now?
Nice.
I can show you something, right?
The agenda that I want to go over today is
basically first I want a little itty-bitty
intro to give you information and ECMAScript
and Ecma in general.
Went we that you can about the minor features,
the major features, and then a teeny tiny
out show.
Just clarifying that we are going to focus
on the features with a little bit of information
on back and front.
Who is this person running on the stage?
And immediately yelling at you?
My name is Tara Manicsic.
I'm a developer advocate at this great company
called Progress Google Developer Expert, and
the mother of this awkward ball of fluff,
Toshi, but as of five months ago, I'm also
the mother of this adorable chunk of flesh,
Niko.
I did poorly Photoshop my baby on to me for
a picture!
But, thank you!
Do not worry worry, this isn't a photo shop
talk.
Those thighs aren't Photoshopped!
I want to do a little bit of an intro about
Ecma and ECMAScript.
So, like any good super hero, I feel that
ECMAScript has an origin story.
It starts out with Ecma International which
is actually, I learned doing this, I never
cared what Ecma stood for.
I probably should have.
I wanted to look into it now.
Some of you may know it is "European Computer
Manufacturers' Association".
I'm very glad that we shortened it!
This started in 1960 because they saw how
much we were using computers, and it needed
to be standardised.
From then, we knew we needed a standardisation
for JavaScript, and that's where ECMAScript
came into play.
Sun, which is nor Oracle, had the rights to
Java.
Have you heard of Java?
No!
That's the only association you will see between
Java and JavaScript through Oracle.
Since that was taken, they went with the corresponding
standard host, Ecma, and made ECMAScript.
So now you know.
So, like, again, any super hero stories, we
also have these pitfalls and weaknesses that
"build character", right?
For ECMAScript that was ES4 abandoned.
This was the version 4 of ECMAScript that
there were so many political differences in
the group that they just abandoned it.
They couldn't release it or get past their
differences, unfortunately.
Another one is what I like to call ES6 years.
Yes, it's a pun.
It took nearly six years for them to release
from ES5.
To 2009 in December to found 15 in June is
how long it took because it was so bloated.
There were so many things they were excited
to release to JavaScript standard that it
took quite a long time.
But, again, like the super hero arch, from
those arches, we get great things.
For instance, TC39, which is the technical
committee, really started to try harder to
work together and reform and do a lot of work
to make smaller packages come out after ES6
was so big, they decided let's do something
more manageable, like developers.
We break everything into smaller pieces, so
it's more manageable.
That's what they did with these new after
ES6, all the releases after that were much
more manageable.
So, just a quick recap.
I want to say what the proposal process is.
We're talking about our stage 4 proposals,
and these, I always think I know what these
mean, and then I'm dumbfounded when I remember
the actual process of what these proposals
are, because they're stage 0 which is the
strawman, free form bringing in the idea.
Stage 1, because, you know, you have to start
at one because we are programmers, or start
at zero, sorry.
And then stage one is the proposal where you
have the champion of that proposal come in
and advocate for this idea.
They bring in APIs.
They talk about APIs, semantics and algorithms,
and then version two, it's a version of what
will be in the specification.
If it makes it to stage 2, you have a good
likelihood that it's going to make it all
the way through.
But, yet, there are still two more stages.
Stage 3 is it's mostly finished, this is the
candidate.
And it's mostly finished but needs feedback.
And this is the one that is funny to me.
Stage 4, which we will be talking about, is
finished, and I have quotations around that,
because, at this part, it's ready to be included
in the standard, but they need to get test
262 acceptance.
They have to do a two-spec compliant shipping,
that implementations need to pass the test,
significant practical experience with implementation
needs done, and the ECMAScript text editor
must sign up on the spec edit.
It sounds like a lot, but we have a bunch
of features coming out, and they did a good
job of bringing them over into stage four.
So, let's go ahead and jump into the minor
features.
First, I just want to let you know what we
are going to do is basically give a little
high-level what the feature is, the name of
it, who brought it to - who is the champion
of it, or the champions, and then a little
code snippet and a little bit about the compatibility.
First, we have trim start and trim end.
Has anybody used trim left and right?
This is explanatory in a way, taking space
away from the start or the finish.
This is the new alias because not all languages
have a left and right, or they have a left
and right, but some have different ways of
approaching it.
Start in end just make more sense.
This helps you classify what is white space
as well, what is a hard enter, space, tabs.
There is a whole process to it.
It is as simple as this.
You're taking a string that has spaces around
it.
A use case of this, say, you're filling out
a form, and basically, how it goes is maybe
in a CSC you're getting too many extra spaces,
so you need to trim it down.
You get trim start and trim end.
You see, start, finish, and then trim takes
both off.
There you can see the compatibility is good
across the board, i.e. it's a no.
Who would have thunk!
A simple prototyped description.
This is a string parameter that you can pass
on to symbol.
When they made this, their thought was to
help teams communicate across code and communicate
their intention for the code.
I read a comment by Grassbury said we now
not use documentation for this?
I think the more place we put in code that
isn't comments, the better.
You be the judge.
This is what it looks like.
We have created a symbol.
We have passed into a string which is now
the description.
When we log it out, we have symbol log that
contains that parameter or use the getter.description
and get that string.
This again is pretty available.
I got these compatibility charts from MDM,
because they fit really well in slides!
But, some of the information wasn't exactly
right.
Like this is available in Node 11, and they
had it as marked as "no" but then I realised
above their compatibility charts, they have
a link to GitHub, so you can correct any compatibility
errors that you see.
We just have to be proactive.
Okay.
Optional catch binding.
Do people here use try catch much?
It's in the catch clause having a parameter
to bind to the exception.
A lot of people were using this and throwing
it away, because it would cause an error if
you didn't have this parameter.
A common use case for this is say if you're
using json.parse, and you know it's going
to throw an error if it is not json, but you
don't care about the error, but want it to
parse anything that is JSON.
You throw it, log it, you don't think about
it.
In their minds, this was superfluous.
Who has time for extra key strokes?
This ended up being one of the most controversial
minor features, but we will get to that later.
This is what basically it looks like.
You're passing a parameter to your catch clause,
and then usually, you want to log it out,
and do something with it.
Now you can pass up that parameter completely.
It is again, you can see the chart.
I could also just pause and let you look at
the chart for is a second instead of talking
over it.
This is where you know that it is an interesting
situation when the most active issue just
says why?
So, a lot of what I do is read through issues,
be it like with Node modules, or with ECMAScript.
Even as a society, like you in a society,
these are some really, really interesting
thoughts going into how we build our and standardise
our language.
Like it's very inspiring to see how much people
care about it, because we use it every day,
right?
So, I highly recommend looking into this.
Basically, how it started, as the person who
opened the issue, saying that they were pretty
scared, let me just say, what he said, they
were pretty scared that allowing this may
make devs forget about error-handling.
Does everyone here do a good job handling
their errors?
Silence.
So, this is basically, he was saying it's
making production code untraceable, and that
he thinks that errors should be logged, and
we should be considering these errors.
We should not be swallowing them.
It could lead to messy coding, irresponsible
coding.
And a few things of the comeback is basically
that this is making it more intentional, so,
if you're leaving off the parameter, you know
you're leaving off the parameter.
Conduct and Competence Committee be even riskier
to leave it so that people automatically throw
that log and don't think of it.
And there are some cases where you, it's what
you are getting back, you can't log, or it's
just holds up the programme, so, what you're
doing here is kind of taking the road of the
least evil, one may say, and you're quietly
swallowing your errors, and your application
can perform its main job, and you're not compromising
the ability to troubleshoot.
Like, you can always add this.
It's not an option that you can no longer
add the parameter.
Okay, so, we will go at a quicker pace to
get you all moving.
But, prototype.sort is now stable.
This is ECMAScript spec and it made me immediately
wonder what is stable?
This is basically a stable sorting algorithm
if you're take, looking at a list that have
their two keys, they have the same value,
they should, after a sort in the same order
which I will show you in the code.
One quick note, no-one intended, but this,
cut to the quick, is intended, it's getting
rid of quick sort and instead using Trim sort,
made by Tim Peters in 2002, and he's making
it more proficient by using binary insertion
sort and improving the merge sort, which actually
allows it to work way better with the arrays
that are already sorted.
So it is a very interesting read, and another
one that I highly remedying into one day while
you're waiting for the bus already or on the
train.
This is what it looks like.
We have multiple keys of A that have varying
values.
This this order on top, it goes ACB.
When we sort it by age, we should get ACB
in that same order, and it does that now.
There you go.
Moving on to major features, again, we're
going through this quickly, and please feel
free to come and chat with me after.
I love talking about this stuff.
I will even do another little talk if you
want!
So flat and mat map is very exciting.
Is anybody uses those yet?
Yes!
Right.
How great is flat map?
It's funny how exciting when you get to, "What
features are coming out next?"
Flat is basically - it's recursively concatenating
to the array dependent on how many in your
parameter how many levels your telling it
to go down, and it's based, and then flat
map, simply putting, it's kind of taking map
and then flat, so you're mapping through an
array, and then flattening it to a single-level
array.
There is more to it.
With map where U getting one output element.
It returns a single value.
With Platt map, it's translated to zero or
more output elements.
It can also return non-array values, but that
is less common.
Then there is my favourite part of it which
is smooshgate?
Did anybody hear about that?
Again, we go to the T after the code.
First of all, with flat in general, you see
we have an array with a nested array, with
an array inside of it.
There are three levels here.
If we do flat, it defaults to one layer, and
you have the array that is still nested in
there.
If we pass to that original array, it nests
it all down, or flattens it down to one.
With flat map, with map, you get an array
of arrays, but flat map, you get back an array
of those.
Smooshgate, the thing to me about Smooshgate,
this to me is like a visual representation
of when I tell really corny knock-knock jokes.
There are 74 thumbs-down on this guy's joke!
Michael is one of the champions.
Mood Tools had a polyfill of flatten, and
ECMAScript wanted there to be flatten as the
name of this future.
My husband is a programmer, and he asked me
what is Mood Tools?
Which is a lot of people's reaction.
Basically, you're taking legacy code and it
is stunting the progression of what people
- or what people consider the progression
- of code.
There were a lot of discussions around this.
Basically, making sure that we are adapting
correctly that we are not leaving anybody
behind, so they changed it from flatten to
flat.
As we see now, we have flat, and mat map.
There is no Smoosh.
There was never a Smoosh, might still be a
Smoosh, but probably not.
Compatibility wise, this is where it is available.
Last but not at least, object from families.
I'm a big fan of object.dat families, but
that is taking a list of key-value pairs and
contracting it to an object which is the opposite
of object.entries.
These somebody limitation works really well
together and a good representation of that
is Axel Rauschmeier looks at objects and utilises
them and creates different functions from
underscore.
I was trying to explain to someone how one
of the biggest points of advancing the language
of making the standard is we make all these
short cuts, or I would hardly say short cuts,
actually, intricate libraries to make up for
what we may see as shortcomings in the JavaScript
language to do the job that we need to do.
And so, Underscore was one of those libraries,
again, not a short cut, lots of work, and
really great work, in the Underscore library,
and now we see when we bring something to
the language like Object from Entries how
we could have advanced the language so that
we wouldn't need the other library.
This is what it looks like.
Basically, we start with an object that has
key-value pairs.
When we do object be entries and pass that.
We get array of arrays.
When we want to take it out of there and treat
it as an object, we - it's available on Opera
no matter what MDM says.
Real quick, we won't go over these, but if
you want to have a lunch conversation with
me, there are some really things I found out
digging into, looking into json stringify,
the JSON super set, which somebody was saying,
when people speaking it in Spanish countries
say ...
then there is also the prototype two-string
revision.
Looking into these, I dug into unicode and
ASCII a lot, and there is a lot of really
cool history to that.
But, for now, I would just do a teeny tiny
intro to say, on this stage at 1400 hours,
you will get to see the amazing, part of the
amazing TC39 group to answer all of your questions
that you may have about what is coming, what
has been, how to use things, and their decision-making,
and I also just want to - I know I personified
these two groups as super heroes, but I am
indeed very grateful that they put the time
and energy into basically giving us a better
coding experience, or at least putting their
efforts into trying to give us a better coding
experience and make JavaScript better for
us, so I'm very grateful, and I'm very grateful
that all all here today.
Thank you all very much.